oh she's so beautiful she's beautiful  she's a landscape designer and a  Botanical installation artist that's so  sexy yeah she does like truly amazing  work uh and  um and we met because as you know it's  like when you come when you're when you  have been in an industry for a certain  amount of time you end up feeling like  you've met everyone and your world  becomes smaller and smaller and I got on  the this app to sort of try to meet  people that were outside of my  particular circles and and I ended up  meeting Lily  um and we she I think she messaged me on  like New Year's Eve like I don't know  2018 uh and then we chatted for a while  and then finally met uh months later and  uh and here we are and then we now we  have uh we're married and have a child  and so uh it's beautiful it's really  great